hey guys and welcome to another episode
of the life rippin podcast
congratulations
crazy
[Music]
yes oh my god return of the mac
oh my god
wow i actually loved when i was gonna
start the show differently but i got
that stuck in my head and i liked when
[ __ ] what was the guy who sang that
who's the guy who sings return of the
mac whoever it was he literally in the
middle of the song goes oh my god and
that's great it's great to just
scream sing oh my god who is it
mark morrison a made-up name for a
[ __ ] made-up song return to the mac
by mark marson would be a [ __ ] song
that was in a movie with ray fines in 19
[ __ ] 97 that came out it'll be a fake
song and it would be like a big hit and
you'd be like that would never be a big
hit but it was in real life and that's
when everything started deteriorating is
when return of the mech came out i was
still in new jersey no no i went back to
new jersey that's what it was i went
back to new jersey to visit my friends
and that's when the guy was in the car
singing return of the mac uh while we
were
doing that while we were i was visiting
my old friends anyway it does doesn't
matter what the [ __ ] it doesn't matter
dude we talk about anything in this
podcast and it's fine
but um yeah dude the life ripping
podcast is back congratulations we do it
every week and look at that man we got
that nice shirt look at that shirt it's
a little bit off-white just kind of
keeping it creamy do you know what i
mean not in a disgusting way but in a in
a [ __ ]
such a disrespectful way but the chain
just [ __ ] oops over that word life
just like you're like we want life to
rip but also you want to kind of keep it
fashionable but these are these are over
at chrisalia.com and you can get the
hoodies too the hoodies are a little
more tan the hoodies are
a lot of the sizes are sold out in the
hoodies but this t-shirt um is a little
bit just kind of like off-white and it's
just kind of like keeping it it's you
know what it is honestly it's the vibe
right now that's what it is it's the
vibar end so um go to crystallia.com and
you could also get the the new uh the
new uh set up the whole [ __ ] sorry to
break your heart strong guys sorry sorry
strong guys merch and uh you know keep
it you you do that you support the show
by wearing it you support the show by
buying it or you just listen dude or you
just listen or you're on patreon
patreon.com but whatever dude let's get
that out of the way let's get it out of
the way and we did um
mark morrison wow i would have never
thought of that name ever again if that
oh my god didn't pop into my head and it
did so that's the way the brain works
you know sometimes you think of [ __ ]
[ __ ] for no reason and i did and that
was great um
we put up a new video on more chris
dalia uh complex con with chris went to
complex con um and uh i guess all i have
to say about that is what is it
what is it it's just a [ __ ] place
where guys with weird boots walk around
that's really all it is what is it guys
you got too big of a bags there you
bring too many big bags dude okay so we
went to complex con and as soon as i got
there the guy
i say this in the video and the with
chris video or complex con um for the
well actually let me just back up
complex con is where a bunch of
uh clothing brands and other kinds of
brands lifestyle brands i guess
uh show up and they have booths that
they they buy these booze the company
and some of them have installations and
some of them just kind of have um
what do you call it uh
um
places where you can buy stuff but
they'll have like five shirts hanging up
and you're just like can i buy one of
these or what what's the deal and
they're like yeah what size do you want
and i'm like well you know your boy
keeps it beefy so you know at least
excel and they're like oh okay i'll be
right back and they run to the [ __ ]
parking lot which is [ __ ] which is an
acre away no way further it's far away
and then they gotta wait there till they
bring your size back and so it's like so
[ __ ] not a real good way to deal with
it but
uh it's how it is and so i waited for a
shirt for like 25 minutes while i was
looking around at [ __ ] pants with way
too many pockets on it like i was going
to get them the guy's like you know
these pants these pockets are great
because they're removable yeah just
don't have the pockets on dude when you
got pockets on the knees of pants it got
too many pockets you know how many
things are you [ __ ] carrying around i
get it it's fashion but dude i'm all
about usable functionality dude that's
what i'm all about is usable
functionality
i'm building a house right now and
kristen's like why don't we just make it
so this place is bigger and i'm like for
what make it [ __ ] nice keep the
ceiling low so it's nice and [ __ ]
when we could talk we could hear each
other i'm about usable
functionality man
does the kitchen open up to the dining
does the dining open up to the living
usable functionality now but i also want
walls though i also want walls in the
house because i don't want a whole open
concept because then why because then
why well when i grow up my dad was using
the garbage disposal all the [ __ ]
time i think he used it as the trash can
like dude he'd throw down [ __ ] wicker
chairs he'd be like we're done with this
let's just put it in
and then [ __ ] you'd hear
roar
and then my dad would hit this god damn
it and that's when you knew the garbage
disposal guy had to come god damn it
that's what he would say all the time
dude i'd be like dad would you put down
there he'd be like a whole watermelon
dad you can't put the rind and then the
[ __ ] the whole but i kind of agree
with my dad in a way it's like dude have
something that works period don't have
it be something that works kinda like
dude if i'm gonna put food down there
make sure you can handle rhines you know
what i'm saying like don't be like well
yeah you could throw away half this
orange but the outer side you got to
throw it away and it's like dude
what am i working at the recycle center
like you know make the thing work have
it real sharp blades have real sharp
blades i saw dude we used to buy those
[ __ ] costco knives the guy went door
to door not costco cutco knives and we
gotta go door doors like want to buy
some knives we were like nah and he cut
a penny with his scissors and we were
like dude we're all in we're all in
you're doing some magic [ __ ] like that
and you're telling me i can do it i'm
all in my whole fam's all in give me
four pair of scissors there's four of us
we'll run around with them because we're
all in so if you have scissors that can
cut pennies
you got nine blades in a garbage
disposal that can cut the outside of a
melon all right
so don't [ __ ] with me on that [ __ ] but
yeah dude that would be what my dad did
he put all sorts of [ __ ] down there just
bottle caps and [ __ ] he didn't give a
[ __ ] he put my other brother down i had
three i had another brother and he
you know tried to put him down there um
such a bad joke anyway um you know we
keeps it real and then we do we do a bad
joke we say it's a bad joke and then we
move on dude because life has its bumps
but we roll over them
um so i have no idea what the [ __ ] i was
talking about at all complex con so
um yeah so they just i don't even know
why i started talking about the garbage
disposal but that's how we do it we're
off and running and that's how this
podcast is and it's very important [ __ ]
npr
so
uh
yeah so i was at complex con and they
went to go get the shirt and then
whatever dude it's just like ups had an
installation there where it was just
like a ups truck was there and then they
just had a bunch of boxes and then you
could [ __ ] wait in line
and have a bag they would stamp the ups
on the bag and you could take the bag
home and you could purchase it
sucker okay i mean dude sucker dude
first of all you're a sucker if you go
to the complex con fine whatever i
bought some shirts i went for some
content and it was fine was it too hot
yes was the food too far away yes was a
parking lot even further than where the
food was yes when we got to the food
place was the line too long yes was it
healthy food no well what was it fried
food is that good for me no did i wait
in line a little bit and then get out of
it when i realized that yes did i spend
time yes but did i [ __ ] put the video
up on youtube and did it go bonkers
viral yes so it's all good you know i
keep it dummy viral right
okay
so anyway we went to complex con and um
you know there were just [ __ ] guys
with weird boots and then of course
there's always the thing at any
convention where there's just the naked
chicks that are painted instead of
wearing clothes hey
selegel
like why is that okay just because we're
in a [ __ ] dude i swear to god they do
the craziest jankiest [ __ ] in in in
conventions and they get away with it
just because it's like no it's part of
it dude you could [ __ ] walk up and
have a booth called the stabbin booth
and anyone that walks by you just kind
of slit them a little bit just on their
side as they walk by you poke them in
the abs they'll be like oh on the side
oblique oh and you'll be like hey dude
welcome to stab and con this is the stab
and this is the stab inside of stab and
con and they're like jesus christ you're
making me bleed and they're like that'll
be 250 and they just give it to you and
they're like my god actually can you get
my brother he's coming by soon to be a
good prank and they'd be like oh i gotta
go to the car and get another knife
anyway dude
um
so yeah so complexcon
uh we did that and uh it was what it was
dude i don't know how to [ __ ] be at
that place took a lot of pictures of
people they you know it was really nice
to see some fans you know i really liked
that a lot
um and then i saw people that are like
like sneakily trying to take a picture
and i'm just dude when i see people dude
when you're when you're like [ __ ]
when people know who you are and then
you see people like this like trying to
take pictures like this like anyone ever
holds their [ __ ] phone like this like
this is my favorite when they're just
like this when they're just like this
and you're sitting next to them and
you're and you're like okay i gotta i
think most [ __ ] celebrities are like
i gotta pretend like i don't see this
and just let him get away with it or
tell him to stop but i don't do either
of those things right you know i'm you
know i'm an original right
i'm not a carbon copy so i say hey man
why don't you just ask for a picture
that's what i do and they say oh what oh
what every time the same it's the same
thing oh what that's what they say every
time i say why don't you just take a
picture with me and they say oh okay
okay and then they do it and they say
nope yo buddy have a good day and then
they walk away because nobody's ever
holding their phone like this do you
know what i'm saying we all get it
everybody who [ __ ] by the way people
who are on tv or [ __ ] have followings
we this happens all day to us
right
so you know what you do when i see
somebody [ __ ] uber famous even like
way way famous like way more famous than
me
um
i walk up and i just go like this
right to their face if that's what i
want i go like this because they think
well there's no way he had the audacity
to just walk up and snap me gave away my
secret it's all good right now is the
time where i would hit that runner's
thing but the [ __ ] key map isn't
working ah yes dude it's not working at
all oh dude i quit out of it and i
[ __ ] turned it back on and now it's
[ __ ] working and
yes dude it's loading to hit him up it's
loading the back in black it's loading
the [ __ ] make my dreams come true and
the one thing it loaded at the end was
[ __ ]
[Music]
yes dude the timing is everything but we
move on you know what i mean we move on
dude that was a late runner but we move
on man so we were at complex con and
[ __ ] ups had an installation and then
of course i had to leave
we were uh we were uh yeah we had a good
time so it's okay it's okay i woke up
the next day dude actually you know
what's been happening to me lately
[ __ ] this is the biggest idiot [ __ ]
ever this is hilarious this is so stupid
but um so
if you're a fan of the podcast and if
you're all caught up by the way one of
my favorite things to do is to walk into
a group of people and say are you guys
all caught up on my podcast i do that
when i go to [ __ ] shows like my shows
and i see people in the green room and i
say is everybody caught up on my podcast
to other [ __ ] famous people and then
we all have a laugh dude but that's just
like a [ __ ] that's just like you know
what i mean that's just
that's just like a little taste of what
i that's just like a taste of humor you
know what i mean for you guys but um
uh so yeah so i you know if you're if
you listen to the show you know i take
gabapentin to keep you know to for
i guess it's for anxiety i don't really
feel like it does anything to my anxiety
but also it's supposed to keep my
restless leg syndrome a little bit at
bay now it did in the beginning and then
it stopped so the only only thing that
helps it is busting you know that that's
the only thing that helps my restless
syndrome because
when
you do busting it provides a nice
dopamine shot inside your brain and then
it releases inside your body and then
you could conk out at least for me
that's how it works
um and you know it's legit because i
googled it and it was in an issue of
cosmopolitan in 2012. so bustin helps
rls anyway
um
i still take the gabapentin because i
think that i should be taking it because
it's a good thing to take to keep my
anxiety at bay as well so i take 300
milligrams or whatever the [ __ ] before i
go to bed now
uh that's pretty much what i i don't
really go to i don't travel to zanny
island too much anymore i don't take
xanax i do have them but i don't really
take them right
um anyway uh i take also lexapro to keep
my ocd in check yes i actually have ocd
i'm not just one of those [ __ ] chicks
that's like oh my god i'm so ocd i love
to have my room clean and i love jackets
but um so i do actually have it
diagnosed um but um
i also have a bite plate that i use for
my uh tmj disorder so basically all i'm
trying to say is yeah boy he's falling
apart
um so sleep is necessary now
i got a bite plate does it help my tmj
no all right did it a little bit in the
beginning yes that's the whole thing
with medications and also like crutches
or whatever the [ __ ] you're doing with
ailments you're trying to make it better
and keep it good and it works for a
little bit and then it doesn't and then
the problem is you tell the doctor hey
it's feeling a lot better and he's like
good and then you're like oh [ __ ] it's
actually not you go back and you say
actually it's not helping and then the
doctor gets a little bit of a you know
defensive vibe and he's like okay well
you said it was and you're like yeah i
realize it do it but not for the long
haul and you know that's what i mean so
stop trying to [ __ ] do you're a
doctor don't be defensive right
so i realize now i'm sleeping on my side
and i can't [ __ ] sleep on my side
because when i sleep on my side even
though i have the bite plate and it
makes my jaw even it pushes the bottom
of my jaw to the left and it [ __ ]
makes that little soft part unhinge
and [ __ ] stay there and now i wake up
at my jaw not only feels like it's in
pain but it's off to the left
so
i'm up pissed off
i wake up now you know when i wake up i
wake up sometimes at 7 30 or 5 30 or 6
or 8 8 a.m right but then i go back to
sleep right i wake up where a normal
person would wake up and be like you
know what i'm gonna wake up and start my
day i can't get back to sleep but it's
my body and i get pissed and i want to
sleep more and even though i'm awake i
wait it out and sometimes it takes 40
minutes but i still wait it out and i
fall asleep and that's when i have the
hardcore vicious dreams okay now
and then i'm like oh maybe [ __ ] 10 30
or something like that right
so before i fall asleep and i have the
hardcore vicious dreams you wake up what
do you do you wake up what's one of the
first things you do besides pissing you
take it you're parched right so take a
sip of water so
i take a sip of water
and it's very bitter and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] gross
so i'm like ah whatever
fall asleep do some hardcore sleeping
wake up forgot that it was bitter
thought maybe i was dreaming that it was
bitter took another [ __ ] sip of the
water sure enough it's bitter so i'm
like ew gross
so i so
i walk downstairs and kristen is with
calvin and i say to her
babe did you [ __ ] mix up the drinks
because sometimes she has medication
that she just puts half of it in the
water and stirs it around i'm like you
mixed up the [ __ ] drinks you know
like it it got all bitter i got yours
and she's like what do you mean was it
on your side you take it did you take
the one on my side and i'm like nah i
was on my side she's like i didn't put
it on your side i was like what the [ __ ]
is it i don't do that [ __ ] right and she
whatever the conversation
[ __ ] devolved and it's fine
i wrote it off a [ __ ] week or two
goes by and then i wake up in the middle
of the night parched and sure enough
the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
is bitter the water's bitter and i know
now
that i'm in control of this water
because it already happened to me once
and for once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me right that's how it goes
that's how the saying goes so i know i'm
in control of this water so either
either someone is breaking into my house
and drugging me or
kristen is secretly putting stuff in my
drink or
it's my fault and i don't want it to be
the last one at all i'd rather someone
be breaking in and [ __ ] with me or
kristen b to be doing a prank and you
know how i feel about pranks i hate him
that's what unfunny people do
so
i
oh by the way [ __ ] i i did have an uh
prank show on in development
and netflix i just want to say that's
what they were saying it was it was
never supposed to be a prank show i
don't know why they [ __ ] put that in
the news by that so don't be all coming
at me like oh yeah you don't like prince
well would you do prank show it was
never supposed to be a prank show anyway
so uh
so i
i'm like what the [ __ ] i it's bitter
again and not only that it's bitter and
i realize there's something in my mouth
so now i immediately think oh
a spider went in my water and i don't
know why i think this but that's what i
think and i'm
it's it's the amount of certainty that i
have that it's a spider that went in my
water the amount of certainty was was
like oh well chris are there clouds in
the sky oh well yes right
and even if you can't see them well
certainly they're there somewhere
right that's how i would so i get up
because there's something in my mouth
walk over to the bathroom like a zombie
because i'm half asleep and then i spit
out in the toilet bowl take a tinkle and
i don't have my glasses on so i'm trying
to look at what's in the [ __ ] toilet
bowl i'm trying to see the spider i see
nothing so now i'm like you know what i
dreamt it
i'm like you know what i [ __ ] dreamt
it [ __ ] it i'm going back to sleep i'm
having dreams of of like waking up and
tasting water and it's [ __ ] tasting
the way it's tasting because i'm half
asleep so i go back to sleep and then i
wake up and i drink it and it's [ __ ]
dude
yes it's bitter again
[Music]
two of those because it was bitter twice
and as a matter of fact the first time
and he did it again
yes dude the water's bitter yes do i
have a brain tumor right
because water's just water water tastes
like nothin
[Music]
hey there you know finding the right
supplements to fit your lifestyle it can
be hard all right in a sea of marketing
and hype brands often skip out what's
important quality ingredients right
hrsupplements.com provides pure and lab
tested products at an affordable price
hrsupplements.com offers a wide variety
of supplement brands for all lifestyles
muscle empire for the muscle conscious
gym goers
harvest naturals for the immunity
focused and for those needing to add
that extra bit of edge to their focus
uh the bottom line is no matter what
your lifestyle
hrsupplements.com has you covered with
over
150 lab tested products
i like the uh pre-workout powder
it gets me in the mood for a workout i
you know i take it and then boom all of
a sudden i'm working out and i'm more
shredded it goes by it's fun i'm into it
you know what i mean sometimes you're
not into the workout but you are when
you take this and then i go in and i'm
just pumped and i'm having i'm having a
good time and i'm keeping it shredded
you know me uh with hr supplements wide
variety of products and brands i can be
the healthiest version of myself and so
can you their website makes it easy to
browse and build my ideal supplement
stack and they even have pre-built
stacks available so that's cool you
don't have to do the work if you don't
want to that's why i love hr supplements
and it's why you love them too so treat
your body right this holiday season head
over to
hrsupplements.com to get 20 off your
first order by using my code congrats at
checkout
[Music]
so i get up and now i'm pissed i'm like
how the [ __ ] is it i mean i'm so 41.
what the [ __ ] is a [ __ ] goddamn water
tasting all [ __ ]
and i go back to look in the toilet bowl
again because i'm like i'm gonna find
this [ __ ] spider dude the
amount of energy that i'm spending on
this [ __ ] is hilarious okay and i
look and i see
nothing
again and there's the bull the bulls got
piss in it still i don't i don't flush
i'd like to say you know me i like to
save water right
so
i'm like all right i gotta go really
investigate this water i gotta go look
and see if it's a different color or
whatever the [ __ ] and i go
to
the [ __ ]
bottle of water and i look in it and
there's like this [ __ ]
weird white little like it looks like a
plastic bag thing i mean really little
like what the [ __ ] is this
and i look and i i pour it out into my
hand over the sink and i'm [ __ ] with
it and it's like all gooey and [ __ ] and
i'm ripping it apart but i'm like dude
you know when like bodies are in the
water for a long time they get all water
logged in purple and [ __ ] so i'm like oh
well this could be [ __ ] anything
right if humans end up looking like
waterlogged trolls when they're in the
[ __ ] lake for a week then what the
[ __ ] could this be this was in here for
a night and it's a really little thing
that was submerged right
so
i'm like pulling it apart and then i
look closely to this thing and it's got
like three little numbers and letters or
four of them or whatever and that's when
i realized it was half a pill dude
here's the thing
i was taking my gabapentin as i was
going to bed and my bite plate was
blocking one of the gabapentins and
keeping it backwashed into the arrowhead
bottle of water and disintegrating into
it and i was waking up and drinking it
anyway so even though my bite plate was
[ __ ] with me i still got the right
dose such a gabapentin
[Music]
dude
yes dude i [ __ ] i win i win dude i
love when i win even though i [ __ ]
think i'm losing man [ __ ] yeah man you
know he keeps getting the right dosage
of gabapentin and it still doesn't help
his rls and he results to boston
yeah dude
oh my god return of the mack
[ __ ] yeah dude he tells stories too long
but the babies are with them dude
because this is a cult and we'll be in
high grass sharing ideas wearing all
white or maybe all blue because all
white is [ __ ] synonymous with the kkk
outside of a log cabin in the daytime
and inside of that log cabin at night
dude you're with me dude
oh man
[ __ ] yeah
man it's so awesome dude life
right
it's so awesome that sometimes you're
driving home from a place when i was
driving home from a place recently
with kristin and uh this guy's just
driving next to us and he looks at me hi
as a [ __ ] dude hi the
[ __ ]
and uh
higher than the [ __ ]
did i make it up who knows who cares
and um
what how about the song that goes my gun
wait
my whip talked to me watch talk to me my
god my gun talk to me blow it up homie
where's translator um so
i was so we're driving and then this guy
drives by
and he's higher than a [ __ ] do
it and he's in the passenger seat and
this chick is driving and he looks at me
and he's laughing and i'm like oh this
guy is blasted out of his mind but also
maybe he recognizes me i don't know
i mean this guy could think i'm [ __ ]
chris angel for all i mean he's so high
[ __ ] it he's so high he could think i'm
jeffrey rush right
um
i mean i look a little bit like chris
angel but this guy's so high i could
[ __ ] be
uh christian bale when he was playing uh
the vice president dick cheney
i i don't know what he's seeing but he's
laughing and his face are she's so red
uh
and he's like
what's up dude and i'm like hey man he's
like nice car i'm like cool thanks and
he says wanna buy a dog
and
those are the weirdest two sentences
together to say to anybody nice car
and then wanna buy a dog okay because of
course i don't wanna buy a dog
right because who wants to buy a dog
first of all
if you want to buy a dog
rescue a dog right but if you don't want
to find if you want to buy a purebred
okay but then you go to the place right
you don't just
have a guy in a ford explorer drive up
with his tongue hanging out of the
window the guy and then he says want to
buy a dog and i say what are you talking
about
you have dogs and he goes like this
and lifts up his arms he's holding three
french bulldogs little puppies and i'm
just like oh [ __ ] and kristen is so
she's just already starts thinking oh
this is something is like her mind
immediately goes to oh they're breeding
them for cage fighting that's what they
are they're bait dogs they're bait dogs
for the cage that's what they are
they're bait dogs like literally like i
look over at kristen and her eyes are
welling up and i'm like maybe it's fine
they're probably fine he's just trying
to make some money and i was like what
what do you have three french bulldogs
for and he's and he's like oh dude i'm
going to sell him for 5 000 each but if
you want 3 000 for you and i'm just like
hey man don't negotiate because i didn't
even want it in the first place
anyway i got two but um
no yeah so weird la is [ __ ] crazy
bonkers dude it's the end of the world
is my point it's the end of the [ __ ]
world guys are outside of [ __ ] ford
explorers just
hawking french bulldogs the most sought
after [ __ ] dogs that you could
possibly get by the way
french bulldogs go for like you know
you could buy a [ __ ] lamborghini
eures for the price of a bench
a french bulldog i'll say i'll say
french bench uh french bulldog
foghorn leghorn
been doing a lot of [ __ ] watching
this documentary the toys that made us
and i watched the teenage mutant ninja
turtles one with with uh
for the toys i didn't realize how
successful teenage mutant ninja turtles
teenage mutant ninja turtles dude and
[ __ ] we watched it we and i was like
man i love these toys and kristen was
like that's so cool you like these toys
and i was like hell yeah dude and she
was like and she was like oh cool and so
i was like let's watch it let's watch
the first episode of teenage ninja
turtles ever with calvin
because
i didn't really get to do that with my
dad my dad tried to watch the entry new
turtles three times and each time he
tried to watch it it was the same
episode that he had already seen but
that's how [ __ ] tv worked back then
you know what i mean that's how tv
worked back then you couldn't just
stream it here we are we could stream it
i was like let's start it with the first
episode
and watch it with calvin it was very
special only for me calvin didn't even
watch it at all but i watched the first
show and um
yeah that [ __ ] it's crazy that
nostalgia huh that [ __ ] that just comes
back to you immediately just i'm like
what is what was the theme song and then
again and then immediately it's just
like teen it i'm just like teenage
mutant ninja turtles
they're heroes in a half shell and
they're green and do it and i'm just
like and they're green age mutant ninja
turt and then and then kristen's like
green age ninja turtles she thought she
was gonna catch me and i was like yup
that's what it is when the evil shredder
attacks these turtle boys don't cut them
no slack and i go up dude because i sing
well i don't just [ __ ] do the harmony
i go up
right or the melody i do the harmony
i'll do the harmony even if nobody's
singing with me that's how [ __ ]
ridiculously
uh in tune with my own voice i am right
so she tried to embarrass me and be like
green age me and nature's like yes
that's that's what it is actually they
say teenage over the green and it sounds
like greeny so
um
anyway it was good and it was fun and i
i enjoyed watching it with calvin even
though he didn't even give a [ __ ]
it's crazy how bad [ __ ] is back then
like we even watched and and it's good
right because for what it was but we
even watched back to the future and dude
there's some [ __ ] in back to the future
where you're like oh my god that would
never fly now look at how [ __ ] ridic
and back to future is one of the best
movies of all time i stand by that dude
you guys stand for something that's one
of the things i stand for
and uh it's uh
dude i have a friend he's like a kind of
like a movie dork and i i immediately
said what number i texted him back to
the future and i was like what number
back to the future uh what what is your
top
out of
how do i say this
out of your top 10 what rank is back to
the future of the movie at the top 10
movies and he wrote back four oh dude
who would know immediately
he just said four
[Laughter]
dude the text came through
four that's it dude that was it i
haven't talked to him in months
at a top 10 out of your first 10 what
what what what number is your [ __ ]
back the future
four
huge dark
his one is e.t
dark
i told him you gotta have a new number
one and he said
yeah what's wrong with et and i said
nothing
schindler's list is out
there's other movies man even pick
[ __ ] you know
pick some with the rock in it even i
don't give a [ __ ] but update your
favorite movie dude if your favorite
movie is from [ __ ] 1960 or whatever i
know et's in the 80s but like some
people would like stand by you'll be
like who's your favorite one time i
asked my grandma i was like who's your
favorite actor and she was like gregory
peck i'm like the [ __ ] out of here dude
the [ __ ] out update it grandma
update it carmela that was my grandma's
name because i'm so [ __ ] italian
and i have an uncle vinny and a cousin
butch dude you forget who the [ __ ]
you're listening to
i keep it so italian i'm practically in
the group the firm with nas foxy brown
and ag
they always [ __ ] you know did like
that [ __ ] mob boss
rapping style [ __ ] who am i explaining
myself
anyway dude
i'm just like when the when the when the
evil shredder attacks these turtle boys
don't cut them no slack harmony
um
dude did you know that [ __ ] uh the
guy who wrote the g the jingle of
teenage mutant ninja turtles is the guy
who created two and a half men
that's
the truth
it's the actual guy not a guy with the
same name
it's the god what's his name chuck
laurie that's the guy who wrote the
jingle for the ninja nose not only that
dude
he's the guy who he doesn't sing it but
he's the guy who does the ad-libs in it
like give me a break
these turtle boys give me a break
he's the guy who does those voices dude
chuck laurie writes the [ __ ] teenager
ninja turtles jingle which is ill as
[ __ ] dude
so my question chuck laurie is
what the [ __ ] happened when you wrote
man
that intro song
sucks donkey dick
dude two and a half men
was the worst intro song
ever
man
first of all it's about ladies man
and the jingles the gayest jingle of all
like i don't know how [ __ ] gays
didn't put that in the front line of
their parades
just looping it over making a diplo song
out of it where the beat dropped and
[ __ ] a bunch of just
guys just explode jizz like [ __ ] the
the the literal
parade could just be like man man man
man man
all over the gay crowd and the gay
crowds love how is it not that dude how
is it still i'm coming up dude that's
old [ __ ] that's the gregory peck of the
news it's like dude
man
so gay
chuck laurie was and i [ __ ] was
sitting there and i was like chuck
laurie did this [ __ ]
and kristen was like well that just goes
to show you and i go stop don't want to
hear the rest of it
and of course she said you know talent
just is going to find i find a way i'm
just like dude i don't i don't have
these kinds of conversation i don't have
the whole well you know if you're
talented it comes through it i don't
have those conversations i don't have
the whole talent finds away
conversations this is not the kind of
conversation i want at [ __ ] 11 a.m on
a saturday just give me my iced
americano i just woke up and drank some
bitter water
man
can we play it or no
probably not
that sucks that just means that you can
buy it somewhere
dude if i play the the two and a half
men
thing
we get we'll get demonetized which sucks
because not because i can't play it but
because that means you can buy that
[ __ ] song somewhere
what's up with pete davidson
dude he's like
is he [ __ ]
nutella
he's just basically
because chicks are just always like
oh i love nutella
and they feel the same way about pete
davidson i mean every girl i've ever met
loves pete davidson
everyone what is it about this dude
i like the guy he's a buddy of mine i
[ __ ]
always liked him we've had good times
together
funny dude i personally think he's a
star
but what the [ __ ] is the deal it's just
like pete davidson
first it was ariana grande i don't know
if it's grand or grande or grant gran
i think it's venti and then it was uh
another one
like up and coming star another one then
kate beckinsale he hit the old [ __ ] he
was like oh i'll keep it nostalgic
you know
making me all [ __ ] bent out of [ __ ]
oh you're dating cape oh you take oh
you're dating okay oh you're dating kate
peckinsell okay well yeah pearl harbor
was pearl harbor [ __ ] sucked michael
bay didn't even really but whatever it's
okay she was in that but yeah no it's
good do it do it do it
and then now he's dating kim kardashian
i guess i don't even know they were like
holding hands on a roller coaster
and [ __ ] it's like dude hey hey pete
are you nutella
what's the
deal girls will just put you on
everything
and devour you
it's amazing
it's actually amazing
he's cool man he's [ __ ] cool you know
what it is it's that whole i i don't
know really what's happening thing that
chick's like right like pete like a
[ __ ] car crash could happen and pete
would just be like i don't you know it's
like i hope everyone's okay and you'll
be like pete you're in it you know and
and girls just find that sexy as [ __ ]
dude i mean the guy's got wacky tattoos
nobody gets more nobody gets more [ __ ]
than a guy with wacky tattoos for real
you like stevo oh that dude forget it
stevo in [ __ ] 2000 whatever
stevo
i love it man
you gotta [ __ ] you know it's like
every time a white guy
figures it out i'm happy these days you
know because white guys really aren't
figuring it out
right it's always like if you [ __ ] if
you like you see donald glover you're
like oh of course he's dating okay yes i
get it donald glover i get it okay
because that's what's up even if it's
danny glover you're like you know i
still get it you know it's not a white
guy but it's [ __ ] pete davidson
you've cracked the code nowadays where i
see young white comics i'm like you
better be undeniable
it's not that easy for a white dude
anymore
you better be undeniable
pete found the side he was like i'm
hilarious but also i'll just [ __ ]
figure out how to be nutella to these
chicks
amplify amplify double it double i'm
gonna keep doubling until they kill me
i can't say the real quote
because it's got the n word in it but
that's what tupac said
yeah man
um
it's so weird man i was watching like
the hollywood thing is like when you
meet somebody and you date somebody it's
just like you you get all this press
about you and then you become in the
system and then all of a sudden you're
one of those guys and like i was looking
at a [ __ ] video of kevin hart who
seems like a [ __ ] fantastic dad by
the way and he was on the court the
basketball court and
and
he had his son with him and he was like
the players was all like they were all
talking to the kid and the caption on
the thing was kevin hart's the father of
the year because his son was like
hanging out with these guys
and um
i'm just like looking at it and i'm like
they just had they have it all wrong
like kevin hart isn't father of the year
because that like his son he has access
to [ __ ] these things it's that he's
literally hanging out with his son
and he's being a good dad because he
kisses him on the forehead and [ __ ] like
that but like
you know just because mellow anthony or
whoever the [ __ ] his name is i don't
even know anymore but i think that's a
guy's name gave him david's son to the
shoes it's like that's not what makes a
good dad right we glorify these [ __ ]
things and like here's the other thing
too like after everything that i went
through like all these [ __ ] who
just like backstabbed me and just turned
on me without even asking me any
questions about it right who just didn't
even call me up and say hey what's going
on they were all of a sudden just like
[ __ ] them we don't need [ __ ] them right
like friends people that i thought were
my friends
like it's just like this this [ __ ] is
just it's so fake dude it's so fake like
that's not the important [ __ ] man
and i was like how is how is
i said to my therapist i was like how is
calvin
gonna know
uh
that like the [ __ ] that was said about
me is untrue
and my therapist said you're he's just
gonna know because he's gonna know you
and i was like
sometimes you say the most simplest [ __ ]
dude a therapist
sometimes says the most simplest [ __ ] it
puts everything into [ __ ] perspective
and dude
you're like you know what you're right
he's gonna know me dude what am i
worried about something that's gonna
[ __ ]
just be the best dad you could [ __ ]
be and that doesn't involve what you
have and what you get and [ __ ] like that
i don't want to get all [ __ ] serious
but
speaking of me i don't not wanting to
get all serious the travis scott thing
uh
11 people died dude or something like
that which is absolutely [ __ ] crazy
this travis scott thing at astroworld
yeah it's really [ __ ] sad
i have a lot of [ __ ] i want to say about
this i don't know if i'll say it and i
don't know if it'll come out right but i
was in the shower the other way talking
about it by myself and i was absolutely
killing it
i was just washing my armpits and
another thing you know you [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't get it you know
you're saying this and it's that you
ever be in the shower just besides say
[ __ ] singing i'll be in a world-class
debate
people are like yeah you sing in the
shower like that's the funny thing [ __ ]
singing bro i'm [ __ ] killing it i'm
on npr telling all those [ __ ]
i'm tupac on those brothers and your
[ __ ] don't actually it doesn't
actually matter but this stupid [ __ ]
that you're talking about doesn't matter
and they're all like turning like oh man
he's kind of right dude
i got the whole npr [ __ ]
quitting their jobs in my shower
but this travis scott [ __ ] happened um
apparently there wasn't enough security
i don't know they didn't have enough you
know what the whole [ __ ] thing is for
me i don't know what happened we don't
know what all we know is the end result
11 people died or whatever it is
we don't know what happened you don't
know what happened you don't really know
how it happened and you don't know who
did what and guess what you also don't
know you don't know that travis scott
saw people dying and kept performing
here's the thing that's driving me nuts
dude
everybody is saying they're trying to
cancel travis scott because he should
have known his concerts are toxic his
concerts are dangerous and he knew what
he was doing and these are old clips we
pulled up now somehow we're just [ __ ]
showing them for they're just seeing the
light of day now even though we're all
saying we always knew he was toxic and
he always knew he was toxic and now and
now this is what happened and see what
happens if we could have prevented it
when it's like you were holding on to
the video anyway what the [ __ ] were you
holding on to the video for were you
waiting for somebody to die
oh but it's travis's fault
everyone's saying it's travis's fault he
needs to nike should chill on travis he
should be banned from [ __ ] coachella
oh because it's travis's fault because
why because [ __ ] uh niall horan who i
[ __ ] love did a concert with the
guitar and stopped in the middle of it
and said hold on they're acting up and
people we have to make sure that they're
safe why because because he's a good guy
and because [ __ ] that absolutely
makes sense when some guy's strumming
his guitar and because you could stop
and be like hold on guys i see something
in the front row
and this is unsafe but astroworld travis
scott literally there's a [ __ ]
phoenix coming out of the ashes on fire
pyrotechnics [ __ ] uh uh clouds and
smoke and loud ass [ __ ] hip hop music
and and you think that travis scott saw
in the crowd somehow
10 different people dying and
and saw that and then thought you know
what [ __ ] it this next one's about my
rims
you actually think that these
[ __ ] on tick-tock are going
viral like i was a medic i was in emt i
was at the concert and you know what it
was so hard to breathe yeah it was hard
to breathe and travis should be stopped
and travis should stop yeah oh travis
should stop oh it's travis's fault it's
travis's fault
it's his fault travis is a singer dude
travis is a singer and as a matter of
fact he was the only one that wasn't in
that crowd the dude was 900 feet in the
air on a [ __ ] pole like he's david
blaine
with cool shoes on
and you think he's busy looking down at
somebody who might be
by the way what about the people who
were passing out pills
for [ __ ] saying there were one thing
that weren't there was a whole article
about how other people were passing out
pills and [ __ ] this [ __ ] was was
making people overdose
what about the security what about
the [ __ ]
police what about
what about you
you were at the concert it's not your
fault at all
yeah it might singularly not be your
fault you might have stood back but you
know what else that means you don't know
what travis saw
you don't know it's his fault
everyone wants to blame the [ __ ]
on top
it all trickles down travis shows up in
some cool shoes and some dreadlocks and
[ __ ] rap some songs
it's a travesty and it sucks and it's
horrible man and my heart [ __ ] breaks
for those kids there was a 10 year old
kid that died
but you're gonna put a video on tick
tock here's why i think travis should be
canceled you're using this [ __ ] for your
agenda
you were in the crowd
it's more your fault than travis's fault
i'm [ __ ] sick and tired of people
just blaming the powerful people
you came up everyone got a participation
trophy everyone got a [ __ ] mr hustle
and because of that you're now 20 years
old saying hey look it's that guy's
fault miles and miles and scores and
acres away when you're right [ __ ]
there when security's there the police
are there the medics were there the
medics are there yeah we shouldn't have
been that way what about how you're the
medic
you just [ __ ] up that's what happened
it was unfortunate and terrible learn
from it
but trying to get [ __ ] nike to not
make a [ __ ] travis scott shoe
everyone's on tick tock i was there and
you know what i couldn't believe it like
they're the [ __ ] goddamn uh uh uh the
new woodward and bernstein cartoon on
fox kids you don't know what the [ __ ]
happened everyone thinks they're a
goddamn investigative reporter dude you
were just there you bought a ticket you
don't know what happened and then i saw
this and then i saw that no you saw what
you saw it was harrowing and it was
horrible and guess what you're not going
to be able to articulate it in one
minute on [ __ ] tick tock
to a [ __ ] lacroix ray beat or
whatever the [ __ ] that rapper is
leroy craig lacroix bray lacroix i don't
know i like lacroix so i just [ __ ]
say lecroy
it's just so [ __ ] backwards dude
you think travis saw people dying i mean
people really think oh he he knew this
thing is toxic and he's [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] knew
you think that this [ __ ] was up
and i'll say it dude people are [ __ ]
and they won't [ __ ] say it
it's soft as [ __ ] man gen z
[ __ ] the [ __ ] up man [ __ ] up sometimes
real [ __ ] happens and it's not that
person's fault you were there you all
[ __ ] up everyone [ __ ] up gen z a lot
of you listen to this podcast
i'm [ __ ] telling you man
i promise you travis scott didn't want
people to die at his [ __ ] concert
it's laughable dude
it's like the wokest of the woke
you're a [ __ ] cubanon it's the same
[ __ ] thing you're believing [ __ ] you
might as well be
s uh at the [ __ ] in dallas waiting
for the real jfk to show up
he's dead [ __ ] you think those q
and out [ __ ] are are out to
lunch you think they're lunatics you're
doing the same [ __ ] thing oh well
travis scott always knew and this and
that he could have been more like a
[ __ ] other you know you don't know
it's like [ __ ] woken on it's the new
q anon
q anon got [ __ ] when trump didn't no
okay all right well [ __ ] it uh okay fine
now there's like eight guys out standing
next to a highway waiting for [ __ ]
jfk to re-emerge that's what q anon is
and these work [ __ ] are like
see
dave chappelle he hates everyone and
then also travis scott needs to go to
jail because he was singing a song while
people died you don't get it dude
and guess what you know what i don't
either i don't either but at least i
shut the [ __ ] up and i'm just talking
[ __ ] to you
and i don't know what the [ __ ] happened
let the police do their [ __ ] goddamn
thing let security figure out where
their flaws were and where their holes
were i'm getting so [ __ ] heated dude
let's just throw one of these in for
[ __ ] good measure
i'm queuing on
i believe that [ __ ] jfk
is coming back and he's that guy who's
got the long hair and the weird beard
whatever the [ __ ] that guy is
just all i'm saying dude travis scott i
know you're listening
and just keep your [ __ ] head up man
you ain't [ __ ] unless you have 10 000
haters and you got you got more than
that so you're doing a lot better
that's that 10 thousand hater rule dude
that i [ __ ]
always think about i put it in my i made
it up it's in my head i've never spoken
out loud but dude everyone's if you got
to you know you ain't [ __ ] until you got
10 000 haters man that's when you really
know you're doing some [ __ ] right so
when you got ten thousand [ __ ]
on twitter yelling at you that you
should die that's when you know you take
a breath and you know you're the
[ __ ] man dude
got way too serious
everybody knows right
everybody knows you all know you're all
woodward and [ __ ] bernstein
okay anyway
this [ __ ] is hilarious
following the this is a this is a moment
a top moment on twitter
that my producer sent me
this is a moment on twitter following
the release of a new trailer of for the
film being the ricardo's first of all
that name sucks being the ricardo's
starring nicole kidman as comedy icon
lucille ball
some
continue to share their disappointment
that deborah messing wasn't cast in the
role instead
all right
first of all i can't believe there's
even one person that thinks that
but there is there's a bunch of people
okay
i just how do you not how do you not go
immediately after even if you think that
you don't think oh well but nicole
kidman's one of the most famous and they
want the oh yeah they want the movie to
make money that's right i forgot
how i don't know how you like these
people don't get how it works
you just need someone who's going to
[ __ ] drive ticket sales
debra messing was famous for his show
105 years ago all right
man
and uh
i just so there's a bunch of people i
guess talking about this and it's a top
thing on twitter
this is kind of [ __ ] sucks okay
and i'll tell you why it sucks it's just
so negative
like
why is the it's so irresponsible of
twitter to put this on as a top moment
it only makes everybody involved feel
bad do you understand what i'm talking
about let's just break it down okay
uh
nicole kidman
reads oh everyone a lot of some a bunch
of people want deborah messing to do the
part and not me okay well good that
makes my day that makes her feel like
[ __ ] deborah messing reads this and
think oh that's nice but of course i
can't get the role because nicole kids
are gonna do it [ __ ] hollywood all right
and it makes the producers think did we
make a mistake it's just so negative
dude the fact that this is a thing
like just
twitter just [ __ ]
talk about how somebody had a kid or
some [ __ ]
or somebody bought balloons i can't wait
till [ __ ]
the [ __ ] changes who knows if it ever
will
oh man i didn't mean to get [ __ ] this
podcast is turning into a drama
it's turning into [ __ ] like some
serious like
li liking speech [ __ ] where you're just
like whoa oh god yeah it's kind of funny
but also it just makes you feel weird
and like it's funny that he's stuttering
but like also it's sad
you know
that's what it is
i decided to cave i'm getting a haircut
i'm i'm not gonna just get my
i'm not gonna do it
i haven't cut my own hair for like a
year and a half i'm caving your boy's
caving all good things come to an end
that choppy [ __ ] thing with the hair
was cool it was nice but it was just
you know
caught caught the back of my head in a
few videos and thought okay
time to sit down in that chair
i'm going to go back to the to
yeah i'm just going to go back to the
place i used to go to and then i'm going
to do it they're going to cut it i'm
going to get mad but then in like three
four five days it's going to start to
look banging right because that's when
haircuts start looking banging they're
really bad and then they start looking
banging
i'm sweating
and that's that while we're done with
another episode of the of the [ __ ]
life ripping uh
podcast congratulations you can go to
our merch store crystalia.com you pick
up this [ __ ] shirt killing it keeping
it cool with the off-white uh we got the
hoodies and we got to make friends in
the comments which is still my favorite
merch although the sorry strong guys
might be we got them all dude go on over
to crystalia.com or subscribe to my
patreon patreon.comcrystalia
full episodes
no ads on youtube full audio and full
video
on
patreon.comcrystalia head on over there
it's only six bucks also there is a
bonus episode every month and you sign
up today for only six bucks you get all
those back bonus episodes as well
so go for it or
don't but you're missing out
patreon.comcrystalia thanks
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
all right here we go
ready